[Music]
bart you have a tesla
have you gl has a tesla jio has a tesla
you guys share everything though have
you used the autopilot feature
to drive
drunk
no because i don't drink
and i don't really drive it very much
but i have driven an autopilot just to
mess around with it yeah
and it's pretty crazy because once you
map where you want to go it will follow
the directions so i'll make sure it stop
during stop signs and stuff i do it on
the freeway so it'll take freeway exits
and go where it needs to go which is
[ __ ] you know when i borrowed geos tesla
i almost crashed it really was an
autopilot what
it i was in autopilot on in the carpool
closest to the bridge i had to tell her
um i should borrow it again
you shouldn't be able to borrow ask me
and i'll let you borrow it thank you
and because we should because it's geo
tesla
on the bridge i mean like on the side
like the the divider in between the two
sides of the freeways like sometimes
it's not so straight like something will
just kind of come out yeah yeah yeah so
it read that even though i was going
like 65 70 miles an hour it read that so
it like diverted me quickly but it
pushed me too far this way oh and there
was cars on this side so i got scared
and it was my first time maybe i should
have just let it do his thing but i
pulled the steering wheel back which
made me start swerving but i was already
at high speeds and stuff like that
luckily i didn't do anything hopefully
luckily i didn't do anything in the car
but that i [ __ ] got super scared and
you were driving drunk right
he was on ketamine what's the article
again yeah it will correct itself though
so a california woman was suspected of
driving under the influence and taken
into custody after using her tesla in
self-driving or autopilot mode
so how do you [ __ ] that up
right yeah how'd she get caught she fall
asleep so the tesla hit a roadside wall
on the freeway and then just kept going
which made chp think that the driver was
not conscious she was passed out right
passed out oh
wow
yeah that's
well yeah that's a problem um so they
they tried the troopers couldn't pull it
over
because it kept kept going dude that's
sick
the only way they could stop the pursuit
was to perform a pit maneuver maybe you
know what that is
i thought that was when you hit the back
the back it spins out yeah that's
exactly what it is so she woke up to the
cops hitting her back and she was like
what the [ __ ] yeah exactly but did it
wake up to the car hit in the side well
no so the self-driving car stopped
itself at the pit maneuver it because
obviously something happened
so then um yeah this girl named carla
she was arrested on suspicion of death
carlos because she lost her car
oh true awesome i like that too that was
fire
it took me a while i was like oh [ __ ] is
right
she's really good she's kind of low um
so tesla has this autopilot system and
basically drivers have misusing all over
the [ __ ] place right it's scary man
i tried it and i just was like
i just gotta i'm a control freak and i
gotta get back to the car and i'm just
like oh i don't trust him man [ __ ] you
robot i don't think i know anybody that
uses the autopilot feature that's like
confident in it like i feel like
everyone's just like no [ __ ] way yeah
so what's the point then my buddy says
that he basically ten and twos it the
whole time while he's autopiloting so
like it's just convenient because he
doesn't have to think it's really good
in stop and go traffic
yeah oh it's really good
yeah because
i get more sleepy and stop and go than i
am in just like a long drive yeah that's
just getting like rock to sleep yeah but
in autopilot it's like very in better
control than even like human like going
back and forth you know because you're
inconsistent with your gas and your
brakes sometimes because you can't like
measure like the distance of like real
crazy stop and go but like that will
just keep you in this really smooth and
that way you can just like chill on your
phone and every single time the thing
like shows that you have to touch and
acknowledge the same way you're just
kind of like
oh that's sick dude i have no confidence
in machines for that yeah no [ __ ] way
bro and stop and go i do because you're
not moving hella fast so even if
something crazy it's a straight line you
know what i mean it could be like a
minor thing anyway yeah the car is also
a tank so if you do crash i feel really
safe in it it's like 5 000 pounds
all the weight is at the bottom because
that's where all the batteries are so
they can't flip over it's almost
impossible to flip wow
it's only i think the test mod x is the
only suv or whatever considered car that
has like a five star rating for safety
wow that's in its class i wouldn't be
surprised if the cop car that did the
pit maneuver got a bigger deck
like you probably hit in the clock
[Laughter]
so these are the these are considered
the downsides of tesla right everyone
always talks about how the autopilot
sucks all this [ __ ] but one of the cool
things about tesla is the fart noise
that's really good wait what's the fart
noise whoopee cushion there's a actual
whoopee cushion in the car where you can
designate where a fart happens so let's
say your buddy falls asleep in the back
you can literally press the whoopee
cushion so it sounds like it comes from
his corner that's elon dude it's [ __ ]
brilliant or you can make the turn
signal have fart sound so instead like
click click dude i love signaling so
good that's great i love seeing i love
it i signal all the time i'm a huge fan
dude i do it all the time nobody else in
this [ __ ] city does though i don't i
don't even know what that sounds like
when you sing no how dare you cause i
don't use it
it wasn't cuz you know what it does it
tells the [ __ ] around me to speed up
so i can't get in so i'm always like you
you learn in california not that that's
what it means in cali yeah no cal you
just signal like this click
i absolutely hate you i've been behind
you before i [ __ ] hate you dude i let
people in all the time
okay so this guy um he says that he got
into um a hit-and-run he says that he
was the victim of a hit-and-run whereas
he's walking behind a tesla tesla hits
him
and then he calls the cops immediately
and it's like yo this tesla [ __ ] hit
me
well
unfortunately tesla's record and we did
this yesterday yeah we did this
yesterday oh that's what we did
yesterday yeah i knew it okay
but yeah dude let me show you i don't
care
i see it
yeah right into it i like how he has an
id in the [ __ ]
he's showing his id yeah yeah he's like
oh you hit me here's my id i'm gonna sue
you
oh my god what an idiot
i like how he just came out and kicked
him too get the [ __ ] out of here dude
walk out of here dude
yeah then you gotta you gotta sell it
you gotta sell it i love that about
tesla's the camera is like running when
it's parked too they can see they can
see ghosts too bro yeah you can turn on
ghost mode we talked about that i would
imagine um
in the
maybe near future when we everybody has
to like switch over to like electric
cars and maybe there's a monopoly for
tesla because they were like early
bitcoin buyers whatever but the point is
that i guess at that point since tesla's
get upgrades like software uh upgrades
through the cloud right so they're
already like internet-based machines
so technically
like
even if there was a high-speed pursuit i
would assume that no criminal would ever
be able to like use a tesla because
maybe in the future like tesla or
whatever could just be like stop that
car yeah you know what i'm saying which
should
mean that if everybody was in some sort
of like monopolized car system there
would be either more safety yeah there's
definitely assets to it if that does
happen
with our legal system could the criminal
counter sue for infringement of rights
if the car if their car got stopped i
don't know where post patriot act 2001
like what rights does anybody actually
have that's true
we gotta we gotta get vaccinated if we
wait just a little bit longer they'll
probably give us our rights back though
just gonna wait a little bit longer
wait just a little bit dude that's like
idiocracy the movie where like they were
and they were running away and then they
got shut down because california was
still where if someone roger house and
he [ __ ] slips and falls in your house
they can still sue you yeah you know so
like the where you draw the line of
what's right or wrong or whatever is
still like crazy blurry crazy dude i
tried slipping the phone in bart's house
i had my socks on
so i was like this is not going to work
out
that's crazy but you fell with the idea
i'm still great
hey look
[ __ ] right in front of your ring cam
steve green
how's your falling
but no do you think that when this chick
gets pulled over or like when she wakes
up you know she gotta have she made a
mess in her underwear right
well guess what guess what guess who
else made a mess in his underwear
michael jordan and these are being
auctioned
wait what this is michael jordan's
underwear what is it
[ __ ] pulled up yesterday what are you
talking about [ __ ] you michael jordan's
underwear upper auction is this is this
a bit what is it is this a bit no no
michael jordan's actual underwear that's
actually a segway that's a segway into
another article
okay can you believe that
i don't even remember that bro i don't
remember [ __ ] i did crazy i remember
any articles
[Laughter]
maybe he's a good host when you [ __ ]
remember it
[Laughter]
nobody seems to remember anything
about this
it's on you man steve's a tyrant bro hey
dude
comedy
trump's all there we go
that's the name of this channel if you
would have showed up on time you would
remember the articles in my dumb ass
head i'm like hey we covered this
yesterday too
[Laughter]
trying to flag it
i'm like wait a minute hold on a second
there's a pattern dude you're mistaken i
guess i read more news than i thought i
did then this [ __ ] puts hot
topic in there so it goes out before
mine
i'm just here like did it that really
happened i didn't think of that that's
better
wait a minute what the [ __ ] i don't know
if that was really michael jordan
yeah that's why we have two hosts for
the competition aspect okay guys i'll
just watch anthony's episode i'm gonna
[ __ ] jack your articles and that's
gonna put them in my timeline your
articles have no shot next article
i'm already doing your articles next
week right now bro that's how [ __ ]
good i'm doing can we switch the days
next week so he does it first no no no
no no no no no no i'm gonna [ __ ] show
up like jim showed up for dwight i'm
gonna wear your exact [ __ ] outfit
this manning jersey that'd be something
you should do yes
don't worry i'll be dressed as a [ __ ]
boy so don't even sweat
necklaces and all kinds of [ __ ] get out
of here dude
i'll have a dildo in both hands i'll be
like maybe i'm anthony
you gotta do that dude we gotta have a
whole switch today
and then just grow this out bro
you don't sit in here with a rick flair
shirt and eight red bulls yeah hey by
the way growing this
you're gonna handle those eight red
bulls bro it takes you a week it's
taking me [ __ ] eight hours bro
[ __ ]
sorry guys i was late because i was
playing poker with my wife down the
street and guess what my dad hates me
hey that's good that's the best anyone's
done on me so far except you had too
much hair wait [ __ ] get out of here
but daddy
dad loves him
while we're watching porno
[Music]